opinions about hypersonic weapons aren't
peaceful some people consider them game
changers because given their extreme
speed it would be impossible to defend
against their attack others say they are
but the latest in a long line of
overhyped weapon systems and are
relatively easy to defend against
because they fly more slowly as they
near their target than ballistic
missiles with comparable ranges others
claim that they will strengthen
conventional deterrence still others
argue they will create instability
between nuclear powers by fueling a
dangerous arms race this debate has
gained greater attention in recent years
as the united states russia and china
have made their own progress in the
field but before explaining what the
three powers have in store we need to
explain what a hypersonic missile is and
differentiate it from a ballistic
missile we are helped by various
entities including the russian council
for international affairs but also the
american missile defense advocacy
alliance that in an article states that
there are two requirements to label a
weapon as hypersonic a speed greater
than mach 5 so more than 5 times that of
sound and the ability to change course
and perform maneuvers both vertical and
horizontal while remaining within the
atmosphere this differentiates it from
ballistic missiles that instead travel
outside the atmosphere and although they
can reach hypersonic speeds and very
often do they have fixed arc
trajectories and poor maneuverability
this image is worth a thousand words an
example of this is the minuteman iii the
us intercontinental ballistic missile
which can reach mach 23 on descent and
could strike russia from silos located
in the western united states within
about 30 minutes from launch traditional
cruise missiles on the other hand fly at
subsonic speeds less than mach 1 and
supersonic speeds between mach 1 and
mach 5. the hypersonic missiles then
divides into two species hypersonic
cruise missiles and hypersonic glide
vehicles the former are powered by
high-speed engines called scramjets and
thanks to them they keep a constant
hypersonic speed and altitude during the
entire flight in contrast the latter
since they have no propulsion system are
usually launched on top of a booster
rocket and then glide through the
atmosphere toward their target at
hypersonic speeds both types can carry
conventional or nuclear payloads the
advantage of these missiles over their
ballistic rivals is quite obvious as
reported by the expert cameron tracy
since hypersonic weapons fly through the
atmosphere they can take advantage of
aerodynamic forces to course correct
over most of their flight path making it
difficult for enemy radars to predict
where they will end ballistic missiles
in contrast can execute corrective
maneuvers only for brief periods during
their initial ascent out of the
atmosphere and final descent to earth
however glide vehicles while having this
bonus suffer from a lower average speed
than ballistic missiles due to
atmospheric flight and above all suffer
from extreme overheating in the
subsystems which not only affects the
aerodynamics of the missile but also
blocks communication with satellites or
other guidance sources thereby worsening
control something that apparently
doesn't affect hypersonic cruise
missiles since they fly slower than
rocket launch systems beyond the debate
surrounding these weapons one thing is
for sure they pose a challenge to many
existing types of medium and long-range
air missile defenses u.s defense
officials say this will require the
development of wholly new intercept
systems supporting technologies and the
new sensor architecture the ones of most
concern are glide vehicles so much so
that the us is developing defense
systems focused on eliminating this type
of threat in the end phase of its flight
since as expert james acton claims it
will travel slower just before reaching
its target due to resistance with the
air thereby being able to be intercepted
more easily who is funding the
development of these engineering marvels
let's take a trip to the united states
i'll tell you just a few numbers the
trump administration had allocated a
total of nearly 6 billion dollars for
all hypersonic related research and
development for fiscal years 2020 and
2021. in may 2021 the biden
administration in its budget request for
fiscal year 2022 added 3.8 billion
dollars with the intention of
accelerating trump's plans by
strengthening conventional deterrence
against russia and china i say
conventional because washington
currently has no plans to keep
hypersonic systems with nuclear warheads
unlike moscow and beijing some pentagon
officials say that the rush to
hypersonic programs is due to the fact
that current american missile
capabilities such as the sea launched
the tomahawk cruise missile or the joint
air to surface standoff missile lack the
maneuverability and speed necessary to
counter evolving adversary threats
especially those from china others
however leverage the competitive aspect
meaning that as michael griffin reports
the united states needs to develop such
weapons to allow it to match what its
adversaries are doing then there is a
debate in the expert community about how
many weapons the us should deploy some
speak of thousands to deter chinese
hypersonic attacks against carriers and
airfields and other critical targets in
the western pacific others speak of
dozens because they should be used
sparingly and exploited for their
surgical strike capabilities in any case
given the internal differences of
opinion within the pentagon hypersonic
weapons will put some pretty significant
future funding challenges on the table
instead what treasures does china hide
china has always been reluctant to
publicly reveal information about its
nuclear forces and likewise very little
is known about beijing's development of
hypersonic weapons overall china's
motivations appear to be to prevail over
american missile defenses and outclass
its offensive weapons in the event of a
war in asia according to expert tongzao
almost all chinese experts agree that
the ability to penetrate the defensive
systems is the most important feature of
hypersonic weapons there are at least
five programs underway in china
including the dongfeng 17 a medium-range
ballistic missile that us officials
estimate has a range of 18 to
2500 kilometers and the speed between
mach 5 and mach 10. we don't know
whether conventional or nuclear but u.s
intelligence has rated it as dual
capable then there would be a
nuclear-capable hypersonic glide missile
prototype known as the shinkong 2 or
steri sky 2 that would be successfully
tested in 2018. instead russia has
publicly unveiled the development of
hypersonic weapons saying they are
intended to ensure that moscow can evade
any future us anti-missile defenses
putin himself said in september 2020
that the u.s withdrawal from the
anti-ballistic missile treaty in 2002
forced russia to develop hypersonic
weapons and in march 2018 when he
introduced a number of new nuclear
weapon launch systems he also talked
about some hypersonic weapons such as
the avant-garde a hypersonic glide
missile that was mounted on ss19
intercontinental missile successfully
tested and deployed in 2019. among those
intended for use in the regional context
i'd mentioned that sircon a c-launched
hypersonic cruise missile and the kinzel
a hypersonic ballistic missile launched
from the only modified fighter bomber
capable of doing so the mig-31k
and deployed a few days ago in the
ukrainian village of deliatin to hit an
underground missile and ammunition depot
i open a parenthesis on this there would
be something strange in moscow's
narrative the images released by the
kremlin are overdrawn and it's difficult
to think that it could have operated
freely in ukrainian airspace so far west
of the front line where there is no
russian air superiority and since
ukrainian air defenses are still
standing they could have detected it and
shut it down some journalists then
reported that the inhabitants of the
surrounding areas wouldn't have heard
any big explosion make your own
judgments but now we come to the
conclusion given the potential risks to
stability posed by hypersonic weapons
arms control is a valuable tool for
mitigating them but one that may remain
utopian in recent years experts have
begun to explore several possible
options the first to measure to ensure
strategic stability is the strengthening
of mutual trust between powers which can
be translated both in the collaboration
to avoid dangerous consequences even in
the absence of formal treatise and in
the increase of transparency thereby
sharing technical details and
information another tool is the banning
of certain types of weapons such as
long-range ballistic missiles see the
russian kinsel and the american agm-183
and where this isn't possible minimizing
the risks posed by these systems by
putting on paper bilateral or trilateral
agreements limiting their number we
don't know what the future holds but
it's likely that none of these
cooperative arms control concepts will
gain support let alone become the basis
for formal agreements between powers
well we are done for today i thank you
all for your attention and see you in
the next video ciao